هنا في زابوس ، هناك مخاوف عميقة
بشأن مستقبل محطة الطاقة النووية
التي استولت عليها
القوات الروسية على بعد 30 ميلاً فقط من هنا
الليلة الماضية.
وقف
هجومهم على محطة الطاقة النووية
التي تمكنا من
تأكيدها بشكل مستقل تشمل
نوعًا واحدًا على الأقل من الضربات الصاروخية أو المدفعية
على أطراف محطة الطاقة النووية
والتي تسببت في نشوب حريق في نفس
الوقت الذي
حذرت فيه الولايات المتحدة  الأمم المتحدة أن لديهم
معلومات استخباراتية تفيد بأن القوات الروسية كانت على
بعد 20 ميلاً فقط من محطة طاقة نووية ثانية على بعد
حوالي 200 ميلاً إلى الغرب
من هنا بها
ثلاثة مفاعلات واحد في زاباريزا ،
وهو الأكبر في أوروبا الذي يحتوي على ستة
مفاعلات ، والبعض منها لديه  تم
إيقاف تشغيله فعليًا ليتم وضعه في
حالة تبريد لا يمكن إغلاقه
معًا وكل هذا يأتي
وسط  تقارير استخباراتية أو
تحليل من الغرب يشير إلى
أن الروس حولوا تكتيكاتهم
الآن إلى مهاجمة مناطق مدنية في
مدن معينة مثل خاركيف وشهدت
هجمات مدمرة باستخدام
أنظمة إطلاق صواريخ متعددة مناطق واسعة من
شمال كييف وبلدات أخرى
شمال كييف وماريوبول  الذي من
المفترض أنه جزء من صفقة للاتفاق على
وقف إطلاق النار لإجلاء
المدنيين ، والذي تم تعليقه الآن وفقًا للبيانات
الصحفية الواردة من الحكومة الأوكرانية
بعد
الهجمات على جذور
سام كيلي سي إن إن في زابوسيا